jean françois foucart secrétaire
national cfc gc en charge des parcours
professionnels de l'emploi et de la
formation bonsoir monsieur foccart merci
d'être avec nous c'est donc une nouvelle
étape aujourd'hui on imagine de la
déception voire de la colère chez vous
la déception c'est sûr de la colère
depuis le départ puisque on s'est battu
depuis le projet de loi sur ce sujet
pour la cfe cgc clairement le
gouvernement veut mettre la pression sur
les faibles ceux qui ont des difficultés
pour retrouver un emploi et aussi avec
une approche adéquat sioniste on l'a vu
le gouvernement n'arrête pas de dire
qu'il ya un million d'emplois qui sont
pas pourvus et en fait il veut que ça
match mais on sait très bien que les
parcours professionnels c'est pas ça
aujourd'hui clairement on
rend la vie extrêmement compliquée aux
chômeurs ça change beaucoup cette
réforme
bat pour les plus précaires le passage
de 4 à 6 mois va faire que ça sera
beaucoup plus dur pour eux d'être
indemnisés et les gens qui ont fait
cette réforme ont oublié que c'était
aussi pour réduire la partie comme ils
s'appellent entre guillemets travail au
noir pour légaliser des choses là
abandonné il ya beaucoup de gens qui
devront éventuellement pu intérêt à
cotiser est repassé dans un niveau du
travail au noir et sur la partie
dégressivité en fait on voit que pour
les cadences et des gens qui ont des
difficultés à retrouver un emploi parce
qu'il suffit pas juste de travail
traverser la rue quand on a perdu un
emploi d'un certain niveau justement ça
va augmenter encore davantage la
précarité des des plus que précaire
ah c'est sûr de toute façon le
gouvernement ça va être des vases
communicants on devrait le retrouver sur
le rsa
amender les personnes qui n'ont pas été
indemnisées vont se retrouver soi sur
les minimas sociaux soit sur la ss mais
devrait se passer des choses pour les
plus de cinquante trois ans ce sont les
trois dernières années qui seront pris
en compte
là aussi coup dur ça va changer les
choses
abbas forcément ça va forcément ça va
changer des choses puisque en perdant 30
% des rémunérations
enfin des indemnités si vous avez encore
des charges que ça soit vos enfants qui
sont dans des écoles ou pour payer votre
est un moment donné il va se passer des
choses c'est clair aujourd'hui il faut
savoir que alizés les personnes veulent
travailler ce qu'on oublie toujours
c'est que 50% des gens qui sont
indemnisés travail chaque mois
dernière question jean-françois faux car
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de dire
familièrement s'est pliée plus de marge
de manoeuvre de la part des syndicats
à l'heure actuelle c'est entre
guillemets c'est plié on attend le
résultat du conseil du conseil d'état
mais vu le réquisitoire le dernier
réquisitoire on pense que de toute façon
ça ça va continuer son bonhomme de
chemin après la seule chose qu'on peut
espérer c'est que il va y avoir de
nouveau une négociation pour que une
nouvelle convention démarre au 1er
novembre 2022
je pense qu'il faudra attendre le
nouveau gouvernement donc ce ne devrait
pas être à sa place devrait être plutôt
en 2023 en début 2023 mais on essaiera
de récupérer ces choses là mais on verra
bien dans quel état et les volontés du
nouveau gouvernement avec la lettre de
cadrage qu'il nous donnera merci
beaucoup jean françois foucart merci
d'avoir été avec nous et c'est la fin de
cette émission